[Music]
look let's go let's go
you got your prospectus
[Music]
no test actually has any impact on your
life including the SATs in real life not
in the fake life that Google teachers
and parents have created so if you
actually believe what I said it gets
real easy real fast the end the sooner
you get out of being fear full of tests
in school
the sooner you've started the process of
actually being a successful human being
yeah we should clip that what yeah
actually that's really true let's keep
this video going I G TV listen I'm being
serious right now like like
hey if you were one that stresses tests
it means you care about micro little
things and that will translate into life
in your 20s 30s and 40s that you'll
worry about your boss's opinion and
you'll worry about getting a mortgage
you're just gonna worry about very micro
like goals which will then make you
stress and you'll just be in that
machine your whole life
then you're gonna care about your kids
being good at school and winning awards
you're just gonna care about the micro
of life it's a huge vulnerability I'll
say it one more time if you didn't catch
at the beginning the sooner you start
not stressing about tests and school is
the beginning of you actually navigating
a happier life
[Music]
what do you want yep it's back what it
is gonna expect hey guys it's Gary Vee
on a Monday morning still feeling the
effects of an incredible episode 4 of
trash talk if you haven't been following
along we're back after a long hiatus 20
bucks per or the pair there nope no
bollocks Oh laser tag awesome cool you
got it
I might just post this thing just me
always going through yellows is key
never stop it yellow
that's different entrepreneur never
never that you've got more time than you
think
the best part of that video is the
lights of bredis [ __ ] when i drive
through it that's what i'm posting you
never stop at yellow why yeah yellows
caution you always have more time in the
backend I literally put disclaimer this
is life advice not driving nice fact
good advice for the US but some people
have been ticketed in third-world
countries for crossing on yellow I'm
like what's a matter with you legendary
this is a good moment with seriously
which is huge the [ __ ]
it's this button I can't find it online
for just a couple others there's like a
funny one of you and Lou d-roc let's try
something can you hear me shake your
head amazing this is gonna be the new
part of trash talk invention episode 4
can you have little Lou look up UNICEF
mugs
cuz I'm miked cuz I'm miked I'm
literally like I realized it on this one
that's the fourth time I'm like the
number one thing that will separate the
difference of you crushing crushing
something or rush and crushing crushing
something is creating clarity around
giving back there's nothing wrong with
that yeah there's nothing wrong with
selling or doing it I don't know what
the [ __ ] you're doing I'm just saying at
an hour a day or a week film it of you
giving advice to former athletes and
that's your content you'll be stunned
how giving back and and not trying to
convert one of the great things I do and
I'm doing it at scale but find a place
where you are doing something where you
generally have no interest in them doing
business video that's why everybody
likes them I genuinely don't I believe
that
80% of the audience that confuse me
inherently as a human cuz we're animals
actually understands that I don't want a
dollar from them and and by the way when
people like what have you done wrong and
I'm always like like I haven't really I
haven't I don't I'm too much of an
immigrant and always have a nest egg and
never put myself in a position to lose
it all cuz I don't care enough about
them like so I'm never gonna be like
that guy but the things I've done wrong
are the things I haven't done the things
I've done wrong are the things I'm not
missed opportunities that are hidden
that I'll never know if what the fuck'd
I don't know what have I done wrong I
should have done it that TV show I
should have gone on that yacht with that
billionaire I should have like a million
things I've done wrong I mean I should
have said yes to Burt I mean the Delfin
my uber is 500 million dollars that's a
lot of money on the only person I
thanked in my book besides my family
like it's not like some random guy
pitched me a my homey because I bought a
house that I wasn't super liquid and
there was a side project so all my
biggest mistakes are the things I
haven't done not the things I've done
that's what a real winner is I really
believe that I really believe that let's
go it's a monster card at a $4.99 excuse
for let's go I got a good one
I got a good Jordan Alvarez the guy I've
been buying yeah I love this dude what's
going on with you I really wanted to ask
you a question but the problem is I
think I know where answers already gonna
be more until you're satisfied and I'm
not these right there wants you but
not really my point I love that that's I
love you because you're just all out
there and that's just you and I might
and I love you for that's right I'm so
scared that people want to be me I just
want them to be themselves as much as I
myself and I love that about you I'm a
big Christian I won't curse I love that
stuff
good for you you've got a completely
figured out on that front a lot of
people start trying to be like me and
it's not natural in the same way that
when I was doing me it was super not
accepted I was me 15 years ago for only
internet and like cursing was not
acceptable the way it is now and two
more people are still not too plenty is
there anything I can help you with
before I run out to this plate
[Music]
I've got a better deal I want you to
come here once a year and work right out
of here for the back cuz you'll pick up
a lot of information through osmosis
just by being in the office for a full
day I'm gonna do something even more fun
send me an email
I'm gonna run out now are you coming
with me um send me an email right now
and say thanks for the visit
I'm do you want a picture real quick
before I leave come back in a month okay
send me an email
yeah in a month I want you to spend the
day here and just get osmosis yeah I'm
positive they go too much you won't Gary
you're welcome back have a great day
[Music]
bring them with me me right now I think
I can held it thank you have a good trip
thanks like this bro I got a D in speech
I'm like clearly one of the great
speakers of all time
[Music]
look I suck at everything out like I'm
sorry I think I'm a good speaker
[Music]
blows me away that like people just want
to drive cynicism into anything and
everything like I want to collect and
flip cards look I understand I have a
lot of followers but not big enough to
move any goddamn market and I'm also
like publicly sharing like the people
I've believed in I also even sold ten be
honest rookie cards at 300 a pop and now
they've moved to almost 600 so I'm not
gonna also about being right or wrong
but these are my hot take opinions like
I think the Erin Fox is a very very very
good basketball player if he gets
massively hurt or underperformed it
doesn't matter what my opinion is I'm
just uh I haven't seen a lot of this
hate and I'm sure it's happening in
community boards and Facebook groups and
behind my back but I'm super pumped to
be flipping and buying and trading and
love being part of this community and
part of every you know every community I
also is part of this community long
before most of the not most but a lot of
the people were even born so you know I
don't know who gets to own a community
but a lot of people feel like they do
and I get that and I'm empathetic I hope
you get to meet everybody or a ton of
people in the Hobby at the National in
Chicago please come say hi whether you
think I'm trying to leave it listen if I
was trying to manipulate there's a lot
of places where I can make a lot more
bunchy then let's come on I just love it
and I've loved it for a very long time
I've just been busy and now finally I
have enough scale to be a little less
busy put off the believe what a lot of
people have known which is
the last two years the market has proven
super super good like there's just a lot
of opportunities in the market I think
the markets got two or three years of
real growth as long as there's no
economic downturn because we all know
cars would be the first thing to go
anyway
I'm excited to meet a lot of people I'm
sure a lot of people or cynical or upset
will be less upset and cynical once they
get to know who I am as a human still
the same off yeah same thing obviously
time okay four minutes away up I'm
concerned see you buddy - now [ __ ] I
can't these minutes matter
let's sing out I'm gonna be there two
minutes but like
it's 4:30 it's a 5 p.m. what is it what
is it 10 minutes before if they closed
doors
6 minutes 6 what is it Oh six minutes to
shore up just they started now right
4:30
just uh just see if there's a 6 o'clock
pestpac
[Music]